taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds what's up
buddy
and taste
buddy it's the taste bud show my name's
joe and i'm sal guys thanks for joining
us as always yeah all right here we are
here we are we're having an interesting
talk before we fired it up today oh yeah
we have we have a lot to cover actually
because i also want to prep them for
what's to come
yes just just do me one favor just do
that and i won't mention it again but i
just to start off you should know when
you sit just make sure this thing on the
mic make sure it's back make sure this
thing on the mic is straight
otherwise outside freaking out but even
even when it's behind my back yeah i
just can't see a point bro
listen to me this i don't want to live
this way i know sweaty but you know
what's weird this sets off my ocd in the
other way
i need to see the point this well you
never broke messy to me you never
brought that up before it's not as bad
as yours obviously but i don't i do not
like that i did forget my glasses you're
gonna have to be doing uh the heavy
reading in this episode all right fair
enough you guys are like bert and ernie
somebody said that the other day
oh maybe we should do that with the
merch merch merch is coming by the way
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait stop we got to start over
we're like a month from we're going to
start over why babe cause we didn't do
the chant we got to start over we got to
do the chicken the episode didn't start
yeah just do it we'll just do it now huh
we ordered a good groove all right all
right fine i say the truth i don't
exactly b
b-a-t-t-l-e battle butts
that's that's
s-t-e buds
pause buds okay
you don't think we should just start it
again no all right all right fine here
we go this is the official start of the
show now welcome to
t-a-s-t-e
punts
i don't know
if people are gonna like that as much as
you but didn't you tell someone didn't
you tell me someone comes to you and
said dude you got it the other night i
was at the stand and after i got off
stage funny thing to be that guy came up
to me i don't remember his name sir if
you're what i'm sure you're watching you
watch the show uh
i i i don't mean to insinuate anything
or slander you in any way i think he was
a little tipsy
because he really was like you gotta
keep the chance man
the chants are awesome and i was
i was like so passionate i was like all
right man cool but he was a nice man so
um
uh or a woman however he identifies i
don't know i shouldn't assume but the
point is is a nice person came out to me
and very passionately said uh you got to
keep the chance
and so that's the church yeah i like it
i like it too i like the first time we
did it don't know
since that's since inception we forgot
to
we did it and that's sort of sort of the
third time no sort of a soft third don't
even worry about answering that question
about it no one needs to know now in the
news grimace has been declared uh that
he's a taste like mcdonald's just
declared he's a taste bud i want to know
something has he always by the way
speaking of grimace
pimp's color pattern color story today
is purp on purp babe yeah it's i don't
know if we can get a you know a shotty
but he's got a a deep nice purple tee on
and then the glasses are 100 purple and
that's the lenses and the frames yes
what pimp rocks
mad stylish he's stylish that's the
first time i've ever used mad as an
adjective swear to god i'm usually very
against it i was after that
and uh and i just think it sounds silly
pimp comes in i'm glad i brought it out
of you
i would say pimp comes in with a dash of
andre 3000. hey
a little bit of andre
it's a little pimp mixed in because he's
always in bold bright patterns and
glasses i agree i agree now did you do
that because of the grimace news
um i'll take i'll just lean into it sure
yeah okay good good
good before we jump into this because
this is a lot to talk about today but we
will keep it going but uh
did you ever see i think it's i'm gonna
get you sucker
i think the pimp is a pimp in that uh
and he's walking and he's in
uh platform shoes and they they are the
heels of the platform shoes
have
their fish tanks they have goldfish in
them that's the movie right yes
this pimp yeah you might yeah there it
is there it is
so check this out so one time when i
used to own this bar i threw this studio
54 party
and um it was pretty wild we blacked out
all the windows and we put out like a
big velvet like rope outs outside and uh
we had cages inside and we got all these
we got a couple of like the old guys
from the neighborhood like because it's
a neighborhood bar too we got some of
the old guys that used to post up at the
end of the bar we got them to agree to
have us paint them head to toe
a hundred percent gold shimmering gold
and they danced in the cages all night i
swear to god as as people the dj was
playing disco classics the place was
packed and there was just old full gold
old men dancing in cages and they were
into it oh yeah yeah my buddy my shout
out bob bobby he's the best um is your
video
this photo and we had the truck outside
with the lights going in the air and
everything and i dressed i went and i
got those shoes
from uh halloween warehouse and like you
know the one on by webster hall really
r.i.p uh shout out halloween warehouse
they're closing down shout out hollywood
shout out to halloween free
shout out ringing people's bells that
you don't know that's right
i got so hammered
that uh
q had to take me out of there but i
could not walk because i was wearing
platform shoes with goldfish in them the
goldfish were fake but there was water
and everything and i almost broke a heel
i had to rent them
you did yeah they they were like
i don't even know what like 100 bucks to
rent but like it's it's it was like a
thousand dollars to own because i guess
they're so okay and you almost broke a
heel like he does in the movie he breaks
the heel and then i don't know oh he
breaks the fish tank open in the movie
doesn't it the heel yeah because people
are making no i mean my i'm sorry i
almost broke my ankle that's what i said
jesus yeah because i was yeah because i
was really walking on like
six inch platform
man jesus did you start the night off
doing well on the platform heels
yeah i mean i i i yeah but that was one
of those nights because i do have the
photo documentation where i was carried
out you know but but on a night when the
old guys are dancing and their bodies
are painted and golden their occasions
like i'm gonna have an extra drink
how did you coerce the old man to go
with the gold paint thing yeah so the
bar i worked at was like a neighborhood
everybody it was like everyone knew
everyone's name they equate this guy to
norm okay you know so it's just all it
was i didn't have to convince him
probably he's probably hanging out and i
used to throw these themed parties like
every three or four months like prom
night 1984 and uh you know like i don't
know all different stuff i had yacht
rock night right
so
he probably was just there and was like
i had the idea and he's like i'll do it
like it was like that wow
wow all right all right well there you
go the uh so i do think you guys need to
discuss what derozan was saying before
we started with the wins and losses yeah
that and this
will launch all right let's let's wrap
up grimace first did did they just name
him a taste bud or he has he always been
a taste they're saying that it's always
been a mystery uh they're not they're
not so he's supposed to committing to it
they're saying it's an option
it's a possibil that he's a taste bud i
don't believe that he's a taste bud i
don't believe that he's as they said a
milkshake uh or just your favorite
purple blob i believe he's your favorite
purple blob i don't think he's anything
there's no purple milkshake
taste buds are not purple
the idea of making a taste bud which
would be a exercise from a human tongue
walk around is disgusting
uh you know but if you look at it like i
mean tongues are kind of pinkish but
maybe they want to go pink but if you
look are those things on our tongue like
is that just him just blowing up those
little
uh that is by the way that is a 10 out
of 10 tweet for mcdonald's it's always
what is grimace and never how is grimace
that's probably grand probably he
probably walks around with that on his
on his shoulders
he said taste but well think about this
though right what do you do when you
taste something tart or sour
what's a grimace did i just grimace
yeah that's a grimace right now grimace
yeah you just yeah you grimaced yeah is
that a
did i just grimace you did
because i think that's what a grimace is
but i realize in the moment that i have
never
i can't back it up i i couldn't tell you
why i think that's a great isn't it
grimace like
it's a great it's a yeah it's a yeah
it's an
unsatisfactory look i never made that
connection yeah an ugly twisted
expression typically expressing disgust
so they they made this character that is
the epitome of disgust
i think may and and
and they're selling food there's a
there's a slight chance
that the connection here is
they looked at it and they said what is
that or or somebody went what is that
and they went oh let's call them grimace
that's like a funny name because you
know or it looks like if you ate this
you would grimace maybe but i do not
believe for a second that this is that
he is supposed to be a taste buddies
furry
come on man i gotta weigh in on this guy
here because i gotta tell you something
uh of course he's backed by a brand that
is a that is a king of all brands but
that is a
sad attempt from the marketing
department right there that is as little
work that looks like they came in in the
morning and someone was like you know
johnson's in today we need to present
them with the characters
today yeah that's today and then he took
a [ __ ] marker and just made a circle
with eyes and he goes yeah this is a
grimace
like it's so low it's so like yeah the
guy went like this
the guy goes the guy goes what's what's
this the guy the boss went like this he
looked at it and he goes he goes what's
this thing's name and the guy goes
i don't care what the real story is
spread that story because that's gonna
be the name it's outrageous because if
you look at the mcdonald's mascots
outside of the clown and the hamburglar
he's looking like a person you got a
pile of [ __ ] you got a you got a bird
who you have to assume is later chopped
up and turned into the mcnuggets right
yeah what should they do in there mayor
mccheese his head is a quarter pounder
which you eat
was it literally a criminal i just
decided to get mcdonald's to eat tonight
for the second time this week for the
second time this week i can't do it
because i had a i had a show in oneonta
last week and on my way home at 1 48 in
the morning i pulled off the road to get
mcdonald's
oh let me tell you this story i got a
story to tell you too in that i got it
earlier this week and i just oh [ __ ] you
can't get it again but look at what i'm
going to look at this motley crew that
they put together first of all the
chicken i haven't seen her in ages
she's she's still seen any of them in
ages except i know mayor mccheese i know
the burglar hamburglar obviously you
know grimace that that [ __ ] that female
chicken
someone yeah
he does look like a butt plug as well um
that chicken i don't know her name and
honestly she was called birdie she's
like the is she like pete best you know
she's like the ringo no she's no she's
the rainbow god bless you i i would
trade my life to be ringing bench ringo
oh i can't stand ringo oh really i'm not
a fan of the beatles period but ringo
really rubs me the wrong way not i know
i don't hate him as much as lennon
lennon's my least favorite beetle wow
i can't stand understand
why you wouldn't like lennon because
um besides the fact that he was like you
know this genius he did have i see he
could see how he could rub people around
genius have you heard the solo records
yeah
what about this
one
mccartney solo records you see where the
brains in that band was yeah i mean
george herrod harrison's i got my mind
set on you is is is not a great song and
that's better than any john lennon solo
record
is imagine is not lennon ugh
yeah
yeah i mean if you oh well look you
can't jump off a roof to that song no i
know and thanks and and i and i give a
piece of chance stinks yeah so this is
christmas stinks he's no no i like this
is christmas instant karma's a good song
instant karma and cold turkey's a good
song how does cold turkey go
i don't know i just remember it's like
pretty good it's like cold turkey
[Laughter]
i don't remember
i don't
remember it's freezing it wasn't
anything like that all you did was try
to sing the words it goes cold turkey
her name is birdie mcdonald's birdie i
remembered wow but her last name is
mcdonald's is she does she have oh
bertie where do you
i don't know that that's correct i think
it might just be saying birdie oh oh
okay birdie bernie the early bird is the
first identifiably female character used
in mcdonald's
mcdonaldland commercials introduced in
1980 to promote the company's new
breakfast
items oh yellow bird wearing a pink
jumpsuit flight capping okay and there
was no chicken on the menu in 80. the
mcnuggets had not emerged yet so that's
interesting how do you know that because
i remember when mcnuggets dropped babe
you think i don't remember that when did
mcnuggets drop i would guess 82. it was
big right that was big news we went to
mcdonald's drive through my friend
frankie janardi said
uh i'm going to get chicken mcnuggets
and i was like what is that and i was
very familiar with mcdonald's
and he got it and he gave me half of one
of his and my balls yeah i was like this
is a game changer
how is the mcnugget still
so
delicious it's it's held in such good
favor still
when everything we know we have
transformed the the persona of health
and food 10 times over since 81 and
people are still like
let me have this pink sludge it's well
it's not pink the pink slide they they
redid the recipes yeah i know definitely
way more real meat now but i still i had
mcdonald's i have them like once twice a
year and every time i have it i'm like
oh i love the taste of this particular
chicken i'm about to have them twice
this week i'm not kidding yeah but when
i leave what are you talking about yeah
but what are you talking about i thought
it's a matter did you feel what are you
talking about because you're proud and
sad at the same time what's the matter
what are you are you above this you
won't eat this babe talk to me about
this i talked to the stefano the other
day tommy ate a whole
pizza by himself he's going through some
stuff
a whole pizza that's so funny and then i
go dude me too i ate nine tacos for
dinner and he didn't respond
i mean he really will just leave you
hanging out he has to give you something
back yeah i mean come on tacos is they
were small okay but they were hardshells
i felt a little guilty sober
yeah i haven't been drinking all week
well uh how does that work you just they
were small dude they were really so how
does that work you step out to the
counter and say nine no no i made this
i made a kit
oh you just made the whole box you ran
the kit i made a pound and a half of
meat which i've ate about half of it
okay so about seventy five three two two
three quarters of a pound of meat and
then the the the el paso shows like
shells i got where it was the 18 pack
and they're small shells so i just you
know but you sit there and you i thought
you bought them that's different no no
did you eat non-consecutive did you like
take a half-hour break
like seven and then i was like an hour
later i was like and then i ate two more
when i was younger i used to work at
like the uh a pizzeria and stuff and i
would bring it home like or i would
order it or bring it home with me and or
if i ever ordered a pizza i would order
it like in the day and then by the night
the pizza was gone so i'd eat eight
slices over the course of the day i
couldn't do that now but like i used to
that's what i i would do that i would
yeah i would go to pizza hut and get a
large pan pizza
meat lovers
and i would eat like four slices as soon
as i got it and then i put it in the
fridge and then i need four later cold
isn't it crazy for a guy who i i love
pizza i worked at a pizzeria i've had
the best pizza but just like the
mcnugget
if you throw pizza out in front of me
i'm like oh pizza it's and you can't get
it in new york anymore there's no pizza
in manhattan anymore so i have been
deprived of pizza hut for years at this
point it's been years
i
will i when i finally have it i'm going
to go nuts on it dude i'm gonna go nuts
on it i'm gonna eat it for days but so
do you think that they introduced birdie
and 80 and then they introduced me there
is a pizza at express but they don't
deliver to where i live
they introduced birdie in 80. yeah and
then in 81 they introduced the mcnugget
and we haven't seen birdie again
no no birdie's birdie's definitely been
around
but i'm just saying it was dirty
nowadays it wasn't weird that when they
introduced her because there was no
chicken on the menu yet is what i'm
saying oh fry guys remember yeah
remember the fry guys they were
different
why were they uh i love a fry guy
wait oh remember the captain
who was like the representative of the
fish i think no that's mccheese oh no
you're right look at the pirate captain
oh yeah who the hell is he
i think he represented the filleto fish
yeah oh yeah and the little
cheeseburgers that would come out of the
treasure chest
oh man mcdonald's and they talked right
it's like so awesome
mcdonald's is so awesome do you remember
the original happy meals when they came
in those plastic like submarines and
stuff no they came in the box with that
with the arches for him one second babe
really
mcdonald's originally happy meals they
came in like plastic submarines
uh
just look up uh uh
look original happy meal yeah look up
happy meal 1981. do they still because i
will tell you this is what we don't need
the happy meal anymore right they don't
do that
no they put it in like a bag it sucks
now and dude you get you know what you
get in it apple slices ugh
i feel so bad for kids today dude
they're getting nothing fun after that
the transformers
oh the kid that kid's getting apple
slices i'm not i'm not giving them what
i eat
i mean you know i mean once in a while a
little fun one of the sad i'm
contemplating not even giving my
children sugar
one of the saddest things i ever heard
was my buddy his daughter turns five i
think and i go would you where'd you
take her like did you take her like out
for a fun birthday meal and he goes
she loves sushi it's her favorite food
so we i was like
yo i wanna honestly you see that whole
like real cast of characters because
they they also got people to go in the
suits and be the captain and be ronald
like i want to throw like a rave i can
just have all those characters we got to
pull this up for the people at home type
in happy meal
classic plastic submarine
we gotta find i've i have found this
before oh boy
pimp
submarine
just left the b out now keep scrolling
down
there it is
up there it is that's it
yeah that seems big it came in a big
plastic and again and you had stickers
and you put this oh there's cancer all
in that plastic you know it dude how how
many cars you understand that thing is
bpa plus pimp make sure you put the
picture up because ssba do you
understand
do you understand that you used to go
through the drive through mcdonald's
with your parents pimp the pink ones
even even better example of it you used
to go to the drive through a mcdonald's
and this is what you got this was your
happy meal and it was filled you had it
goodies
oh my god dude and then you could keep
it look at it look at it unbuilt when
you got to put it together it's really
cynical of the hamburger place
i love it it really caused a nationwide
epidemic the characters seem a little
ironic to me a burglar a clown
yeah
i just mean like luring children in it's
like it's their version of getting this
van i got candy for you
jesus
full of saturated fat let me put it
under the guise of a plastic boat
you know what i mean i should show you
[ __ ] i used to demand mcdonald's i was
having mcdonald's way more than i should
have we all were so what mcdonald's
brass knows what they would do
i'm just saying it's a little cynical to
lure us in with the toys cynical is the
wrong word okay probably is uh
underhanded i would say okay fine
duplicitous i
we're not even on the same head but then
they go ahead and they name the main
character something that you would a
face you would make if you taste
disgusting food
they're all over the place we've been on
this for way too long we've got to move
on here you were telling me that you
speaking of the battle you were telling
me right before this started you tell me
in pimp that you have turned over a new
leaf in your attitude toward this show
explain today's battle is pizza versus
pasta we've been holding we've been
holding on it for for months now
fans have continually asked us to do it
uh we honestly came up with this one on
our own and coincidentally fans have
also asked for it so we know that this
one is going to resonate here's the
thing like right because we were
passionate about it and then people were
also coming up with it and asking for it
uh we always
we're we'll say it right off the bat
pizza's not i think pizza out of every
single episode we've ever done i'm not
sure and i think this is common uh
people would agree not sure that
anything would ever be pizza so we
started saying what could beat pizza and
i'm really hoping that pasta gives it a
run for its money because if you think
pasta on the whole that encompasses so
much so we thought pasta had had a
chance right
but
we both still thought pizza would win
yeah however we both love both
uh and we were like i don't know man i
could fight for and i said before we
started today
give me pasta and sal said i'm not
trying to push you into taking pasta
because it's a guaranteed loss and i
said i don't care i want pasta let's do
this and he said oh snap where are you
coming from and i said my attitude
towards the show has changed if i feel
passionate about the food i just want to
fight for it i don't ever want to take
into account anymore
that i might lose i just want to enjoy
the fight and then we were like wait
do you leave here heavy after a loss
no we i said we had you been losing
sleep on your record and you like kind
of said you kind of you were no but
don't get me wrong sometimes when i have
either a really
uh small like a loss by less than a
percentage yeah man i actually for the
rest of the night i'm
i'm pissed for the rest of the night
yeah pissed off yeah i have left this
apartment wondering if our friendship is
in good standing
you talked to your mom about it i talked
to my mom about it my mom has asked me
unprompted about it uh and i don't know
if you ever see the comments that some
of these fans make but people are taking
this seriously yeah and we'll degrade
either one of us as they as if it's
politics or something right right so i
have a question did you think about this
in between tacos the other night
no no no no i wasn't looking at anything
i was eating tacos
uh nine tacos watching the movie
communion which is a christopher walken
movie where he gets abducted by aliens
never heard of it it sounds amazing it's
okay on paper he's off the plantation in
this thing her reservation what's the
phrase off the reservation both i think
both aren't really offensive well off
the plantation isn't even a thing okay
and i understand it sounds like the same
cadence that ends in a shunt
yeah but he's uh he's he's out of
control but i ate nine tacos while i
watched him get like anally probed
uh it was an enjoyable night so no i
didn't think of much but anyway
uh i saw something you you threw in the
thing and i think it would be a good
battle for future um
kfc versus taco bell i like that yeah i
love it i like that all right so we we
we will get to that at some point but
today's battle is pizza versus pasta
pimp where are we at with time by the
way
okay we should get into the battle
that's it all right here we go
ready yeah
b
ready
ready
b a t t
there you go you did it perfect all
right
you want to start us out yeah pizza
[Laughter]
okay um well
talk about just general convention i
think that people can point one more
thing out please
we're about to hit we're approaching
october we're not there yet but we're
about 11 days out from october 12 days
out
want to squeeze in one more last round
of george show those games next time we
record i think it's gonna be too cold
for george yeah all right oh you know
what before i didn't want to keep doing
this but like have you ever heard of
someone call
um a pair of legs a pair of wheels
yeah yeah okay someone told me they
never heard that before i was like i'm
sure of it on your mind all day no but
you just pointed to your wheels
um i see you're wearing the hat i was
with you when you bought that hat
on vacation yeah yeah all right very
nice
yes it sounds like all we do is fight on
my couch and take vacations
no yeah i know anyway all right
pizza so look there's a reason right
there's a reason why
you you yourself in your life have
probably had a conversation with
hundreds of people where people have
said they've they've offered up
themselves i mean nothing beats pizza i
could eat pizza you have that
conversation if you had to eat one food
every day right i've had that
conversation i've heard it i've
overheard people saying it
inevitably
the answer resoundingly always comes
back pizza so i don't think i really
like i'm saying anything that anyone
would disagree with
i think pizza
is probably my favorite food i think it
is because really i've never
not wanted a slice of pizza not even
clothes for me i've never been like i
have to i love pizza but it's not cool
i'll tell you what i'll tell you this
every time i have pizza
i'm pumping the breaks
i could eat pizza as if i were a
goldfish i could eat myself to pizza
death you understand what i'm saying i
love pizza
and i will go in on pizza as i said
earlier about um pizza hut
uh or or or you know any one of uh
dozens and dozens of places in new york
city or wherever we're in philly we're
near places where i grew up in the
suburbs whatever that's not the point
it still is not in my i don't think it
makes my top 10 favorite foods probably
my top 20 but not my top ten to be
honest with you pizza is not in your top
ten uh
i think you're the only person on the
planet that's not in the top ten i will
go through my top ten sometime but i
just told you now i'm gonna eat
mcdonald's twice in a week oh we know
your number one food is mcdonald's you
brought it up on food
i can't i could go weeks on end without
getting pizza
i could go weeks without it my point
though is i can't go weeks when i am
without my favorite foods i mean cheese
and bread
are like two of the like i i put bread
and butter
up again did we ever do bread and butter
no i think bread and butter could go up
against pizza that's how good i think
bread and butter
i that's bread bread is one of the best
things ever made and i don't mean like
sliced bread you buy at the store but if
you ever go to a bakery or have fresh
baked bread or hot bread brought out for
at a good at a restaurant it's delicious
but
it could not go against pizza even just
getting a loaf of italian bread coming
home throwing it in the oven a little
bit and put a little bread and butter on
there it's like
you could go to school for years and
graduate from some a cat for some some
crazy institution culinary institution
and have a michelin star and make me
your best meal and you could put bread
and butter in another plate and i'd be
like they're as good as each other i i
think that's because butter is that's
not butter is also about but dude cheese
is another thing it's like cheese is and
i know that you really don't eat cheese
well i eat less cheese these days yeah
but you combine those things and then
like the acidity and the sweetness of a
sauce and then i'm just talking about
your regular pizza but
i mean look you have tons of pasta on
your side but you you just if you just
run the board on the types of pizza the
thin crust the chicago style the detroit
style the new york style the crispiness
the the the coal oven pizza the brick
oven so okay so jesus christ i'll take
illios in the goddamn toaster oven so i
mean
now
there's a there's a saying about pizza
we all know it pizza even bad pizza is
okay that's nice
that is 100 they do that is hundred
percent false and i will prove it right
now i will say i've had bad pizza i will
say i have had but it's like hold on
it's hard okay i have had to get pizza i
have had guard i have had
not just bad pizza
horrific pizza yeah disgusting pizza
when pizza is bad name names it is
terrible
illeos right out of the gate oh
stinks
all right most of your frozen pizzas
stink
a lot of a lot of chicago deep dish
pizzas don't don't say that about leos
bro it's terrible i get i get what you
mean but you're telling me there's a
time and a place for illios there's a
time and place no no no
baby
the freezer's door open and there's a
box
and i'm like thank you jesus he lives
jesus you're nuts you're nuts maybe i
might do that over a stouffer's french
bread but there's no way i'm doing that
over helios there's no way i'm doing
that over a mama celeste there's no way
i'm doing it over at digiornos i got
news for you
celeste it's not delivery it's not even
the journals it stinks
you think digiorno stinks it stinks wait
i'm sorry you think wait illios versus
the jornos
you can find i mean i would eat the
jordano's over the ilios but what does
that say
first of all i i mean you can't base the
argument against pizza on ilios all i'm
trying to say is i'm just saying there's
a lot of bad people so for many of us
out there ilios has a time and place
where elios is the thing that's so go to
any one of the we live in new york city
go to one of these
go to one of the 99 cent slices places
it's it's usually pretty bad go to one
of the
hold on hold on you've talked for quite
a while you've been i just started
you're in the middle of talking is like
nine minutes by the way that's not true
joe not in this rewind the tape on the
eight-minute rounds when you kept
talking after because you you ate up six
8 minutes by yourself for talking but
let me just tell you this
even the chain places that are only in
new york okay and i won't name names
because i don't want to disparage my
city
but there are chain places that are
local to new york even though now also
even those places even those places the
ch you know i mean the local chains
they're not that good it's it's okay
okay it's okay it's fine it's passable
now you have a set of stones on you that
you're to come in here and think that
this bread
sauce and cheese concoction can hold a
candle to
lasagna
ravioli my favorite mona got rigatoni in
a meat sauce
spaghetti linguini and clams linguine
clams
pasta fra diavolo
are you out of your mind
if you
if you went to the middle of nowhere
this is the last thing i'll say then you
can speak again
okay all right all right hold on let me
just adjust my attitude for where you're
bringing this okay
okay let's go let's go now because i
told you babe i i want to i'm ready
today let's go go go let's go please
talk let's go yeah all right
i'm just saying if you went to a
restaurant in the middle of nowhere
let's say like you you were in the
depths of of of wyoming right yeah
because this is relatable to people no
no let's just say let's just say okay a
place not known for pizza let's put it
down you're calling out something like
raised pizza there's a hundred locations
in manhattan and saying it sucks but
then you're like
put yourself in my shoes you're in the
middle of the woods in wyoming but
you're not you don't know where i'm
going with this
you're in the middle of wyoming let's
say okay
you go to a restaurant they go we got
two dishes here we got pizza we got
pasta which would you like you know
you're going with that pasta you know
there's no way in hell you're rolling
the dice on that wyoming oh i don't know
if i'm dealing with that pasta
[ __ ]
dude i can make pizza right now go
downstairs get a pizza here we go here
we go every week every week i could i
could go downstairs and do this right
now i mean really all i mean is all i
mean is good no go ahead
i love a bare bottom folks i like to
joke
but you know what i mean by that i mean
a bare bottom article of clothing yeah
bare bottom clothing is the go-to for
guys looking to update their wardrobe
with high quality and made to last
threads without dishing out a small
fortune
it's the internet's best deal yeah on
high quality
versatile men's wear they've got over
ten thousand five star reviews so you
know they're not messing around people i
think when it comes to stuff like this
reviews are a good thing to read uh and
ten thousand five stars don't lie
designed to transition from the couch to
the gym this clothing is for work and
play or whatever you like to do giving
back also is at the core of what bare
bottom does isn't that nice they've
donated over a hundred thousand pairs of
shoes i'm sorry yes they donate they
donated over a hundred thousand pairs of
shorts to children in need uh and
starting this summer they'll be donating
a school lunch for every single item
sold i love the company i love the
quality of the product of the company i
wear it i have a lot of it and i am not
just reading this saying to get it i
think you really like it they have a
wide variety of clothes everything is
soft durable like it feels good the cuts
are really nice in it i like the way
they cut the pants and the shorts the
shorts are above the knee it's just i
would check it out if anything i would
at least check it out guys and uh right
now our listeners get free shipping on
the first order of these super
comfortable threads at
bearbottomclothing.com with the code
taste buds uh just go to bare bottom
clothing and that's bare like bear like
the animal
bottomclothing.com and use taste buds to
get free shipping on your first order
amazon music coming to the dance with
more than 10 million free podcast
episodes to listen to including this one
amazon isn't just for listening to
podcasts though
[ __ ] i'm just going to start it over i'm
sorry
amazon music is coming to the dance with
10 million free podcast episodes to
listen to including ours but not just
for listening to podcasts they have
thousands of music stations and top
playlists to stream this is the
important part for free no matter what
you're listening to you can even go
hands-free with alexa just get the app
and enjoy free listening anywhere on all
your favorite devices no credit card no
subscription required i just downloaded
the app i was listening to music and
podcasts
immediately uh if you've never tried
amazon music what are you waiting for uh
you know everyone knows all the other
popular music apps but they're taking
money from you every single month so
you're gonna love amazon music as much
as we do we're sure of it start
listening for free today head over to
amazon.com taste buds that's amazon
maybe you heard of it dot com slash
taste buds to stream thousands of music
stations and over 10 million podcast
episodes because bezos is a big podcast
fan he watches taste buds jeff if you're
listening and we know that you are thank
you for free amazon.com taste buds
uh uh english muffin like if you have a
you know a jar of salt maybe a nice jar
oreo sauce
a nice bag of shredded parskin
mozzarella and even an english muffin i
go downstairs i have the three hallmark
ingredients i toast an english muffin
throw a sausage cheese on it throw it in
the oven for five minutes that is
delicious sure that is pizza yes
and you also just but you also just pick
the ingredients yourself i'm talking
when you were at the mercy of everything
that might be a bad crust i know but i'm
also scared of what's in that pasta
because what's in it what just the same
stuff in the pizza just the sauce and
the pasta and that's it if they said if
they said
if they said we've got a thing of kraft
uh uh parmesan cheese that comes in the
green tube
right
and they said we got a box of mama
whatever the hell it is spaghetti okay
and we boiled it and we got some rago in
the back i'm taking that i would take
that over the the dice roll pizza any
day of the week because that pizza there
is so much that can go wrong i'll tell
you another thing with pizza pizza is
one of the only foods i can think of
where if it gets bad it gets terrible
and if it gets too good it gets terrible
pizza pizza if you go too far in the
artisan direction it stinks it stinks
somebody comes out and goes well we've
got a caramelized raspberry reduction on
this pizza and we've got a candied
mushroom well when it no longer becomes
a pizza that's fine but that's not truly
true because there's a market for that
and i i've had good artisanal pizza but
look where dude if i'm in wyoming i'm
going for the pizza many places if i'm
in wyoming i'm going for that pizza i'm
not going for
ragu
and and boxed pasta you're gonna get the
same ragu on the pizza and it's gonna be
worse on the pizza than it is on the
possible dance
arguing about a small town side of the
road restaurant that has a menu with two
items on it take it to global there's a
reason it's a global thing there is a
reason why there is a reason why hear
what i'm about to say to you there is a
reason why you could go to almost any
state in this great land of ours and
find
multiple great italian restaurants
and
why when it comes to pizza there's
four neighborhoods you can go to to get
it you can go to new york you can go to
philly you can go to chicago yeah maybe
detroit yeah i know that those are the
places that that like conventionally
have the best pizza to us but i'm just
saying like you can drop me you can gr i
could be walking down the street
somebody could drive up slow in a van
somebody opens the van they club me in
the back of the head they throw
something over my head they kidnap me
they bring me somewhere i just hear a
lot of hustler rustling and bustling i
don't move because i don't want to i
don't know what exactly what's going on
and i don't want to stoke anything and
wind up dead so i don't say anything i
take a 10-hour ride with these people i
hear that conversation i listen to clues
in case i i can make a break and i can
call the police okay okay but i just
take the ride and they end up dumping me
somewhere i roll out i'm famished i love
this so far i love that you've been
clubbed and dumped already i love it
okay
all of a sudden i hit tires screech i'm
still no one's around i feel fit that i
could take the burlap sack off my head
i'm starving i don't even know where i
am i'll google pizza and have it
delivered to me wherever they drop me no
matter what doesn't that say something
to you about pizza you're wrong
you know how i'm saying pizza is
available everywhere at all
fine
what's the number what does it mean it's
good what's the number one thing that
you think
and i will tell you this let me finish
what's the number one you think let's
what's the number one thing you think
worldwide cumulatively in the history of
time that has been delivered the most to
people's homes think about that more
people milk no wrong
milk more people more people in the
world today
than anything else
have had the desire to be like pick up
that phone i need somebody
but i will tell you something you are
right the pizza is the most deliverable
food and it is the most available food
at all times and you know what because
of that i have never been burned more
with a food tasting like crap than pizza
you know how many years i've been on the
road doing comedy and i've sat in a
hotel room at 2 a.m and the only option
was a pizza place in some state that
wasn't good at pizza and i ordered it
and i was sitting there going i just
spent 25 and i ate three bites of this
and it's disgusting
americans eat approximately 100 acres of
pizza each day
350 slices a second
36 percent of all pizza orders want
their pizza that's what's gonna say take
you back to snickers kitkat baby don't
get arrogant because snickers runs the
world and they lost to kitkat you're
right you're right but all i'm saying is
you keep talking about how you got
burned on the side of a road and when
you were doing no no no no no you were
on the side of the road i was in a hotel
no no but i mean it's civilized
yeah a hotel on the side of the road no
on a regular road maybe a major
thoroughfare wherever you are if you're
getting burned with the pizza you're
getting burned with the pasta that's not
true yes it is
yes it is so
don't don't give me the argument that
you're getting pizza roadside in a
midwestern town in a hotel on the side
of the road of course it's going to suck
the pasta i've been burned by pasta you
think i have been burned by pasta take
my shirt off show you all the burns
michael scarn says is it time we
seriously consider putting joe into an
assisted living center
if he chose pasta which i know damn well
he did the answer is clear
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i would like to tell you that is
like already a contender for women i
would like to tell you that pizza when i
say it's my favorite food i swear to you
if if you're not talking like
i've said more times out loud and when
asked this question even in interviews
publicly ravioli is actually my favorite
food you know and i can eat ravioli
every day so i i am there with you on
pasta but it's not gonna mean we're not
even oh my god we didn't even get into
what you can put into the raviolis you
can stuff them with lobster you think
lobster's going on a pizza i'm sure it
has i'm sure it is i mean it's been
topped with everything you know what i'm
sure it's done i love that you just made
the argument that when you try to do put
too much introduce too much to a pizza
it's terrible and then you're like but i
can't even tell you what you could do
with a pasta and then it's a strength
because it sucks yes because lobster on
pizza sucks lobster and ravioli is
amazing yes it's a party yeah pizza
party by the way children have them you
know the term look at this the
tournament
here's a little history the term is
based in violent racial division
splitting most american lock-ups so once
again you're on the side of the racist
elite what once again what does that
even mean
according to the associated press last
week allen was charged with solicitation
of first-degree murder in part thanks to
oh wow this was a specific pizza party
oh i thought idiot
you idiot you just thought that the term
pizza party caused a huge racial divide
it's just that something broke out of
the world what the hell did pimp bring
it up for
i just wrote up the word pizza please
yeah he just highlighted it what kind
of pizza party you know honestly dude
what constitutes a pizza party a pizza
party is a social gathering at which
people bring pizza
no i'll give you this come on i'll give
you this honestly i'll give you this
my birthday's coming up in the fall i
would love to come for you to come to my
pasta party
i know said no one yeah guess what guess
what never been a kid's book named after
pizza plenty of kids books
cloudy with a chance of me
that's not possible all right lady in
the trip the most famous disney scene of
all time
spaghetti between those pooches
were they eating a slice of sicilian
spaghetti between those pooches
no one fantasizes about being a pasta
delivery boy in those adult films
oh oh i i haven't i delivered pizza by
the way for five years hey babe and
pasta because we had both right okay
okay but you're a pizza delivery guy i
mean that pizza boy comes in honestly
dude i'll just say this
i'll just i'll commit i'll put one horse
in the race
you tell me
what beats a beautiful i mean a
well-made and the crust oh the question
here's here's the beats of pepperoni
pizza here's the coffin shot okay here's
the coffin shot on the argument right
i've been to rome have you been to rome
no i've been telling you i'm really
asking no i have not all right i've been
there what they're what the version of
italian pizza is is that what you're
gonna have no no i've been to rome
uh
i
had the best food i've ever had in my
life in rome every night pasta was part
of that every single night
not one of the wonderful restaurants we
went to offered pizza as a dish and when
we got pizza at pizza places in rome it
was mediocre at best i agree because but
that is different it is the king i'm
talking about american like american
like wes like our pizza like over there
they it's it's it's traditionally done i
mean we're not like
tomatoes on it but of course if you go
to rome the pasta is going to be amazing
the best pasta i've ever had has been in
italy as well sure but
the polls are open to worldwide hun okay
i've been to italian restaurants from
guys that came over from italy that own
and operate these places and they'll say
do you want do you trust me do you want
to go off the menu you say yeah not once
have they ever surprised me with an
amazing pizza that you got to try it's
so good no but they'll bring out they'll
bring out a bison ragu pasta or
something like that that's amazing and
incredible with homemade noodles in it
a bison ragu pasta is what he's putting
up against pepperoni pizza bison regular
have you had a bison pot have you had a
biscuit i'm sure it's fine but i
wouldn't have gotten
i wouldn't have gone fine a light red
sauce with biscuits let's talk about
making it are you kidding me somebody
even the process of it
you don't even get it
it's an art form it's fun you take the
leaves you just you sprinkle the cheese
on you put it in the oven you stink it
out i love the process of making pizzas
pasta you gotta you gotta sit there you
gotta flatten it you gotta cut it you
gotta hang it you gotta wait my picture
is on the wall of the collegeville
bakery and deli in collegeville
pennsylvania where i grew up they do
physiology of the day when celebrities
come in and eat i am hanging on that
wall with the likes of ric flair sir
i have put a pizza into the oven that
other folks have mentioned the wall of
joe's pizza oh so what i'm talking about
about
hearing joe's the williamsburg branch
bespoke post is here to take your
adventures to the next level
whatever season you're adventuring in uh
they're partnering with small businesses
and emerging brands to bring you the
most unique goods every month let's
let's talk about what bespoke post is
it's a subscription based service that
monthly sends you really awesome items
as a matter of fact it's called a box of
awesome right that you help curate and
you basically the boxes are cost about
45 bucks but you end up getting like
well over 70 bucks worth of gear and cha
cheese and really fun things there's
things from
you know
weekend bags to knives to to
lotions
my overnight they sent me with me today
yeah because i stayed with you last
night 100 yeah yeah quite romantically i
might add it's cool you go to a box of
awesome.com and take this quiz and they
help like those answers help you create
what they're going to send you they
release new boxes every month across so
many different categories it's free to
sign up you can even skip or cancel at
any single time so you don't have to
worry that you sign up and it's gonna
come every month no matter what you can
choose to pause if you want to uh of
course our listeners are going to get 20
off their first monthly box when they
sign up at box of awesome.com enter our
code tastebuds at checkout it's very
easy that's box of awesome.com code
tastebuds for 20 off your first box i
love this kind of thing this is
subscription-based stuff when it comes
each month and it's different and it's
new it's feel like it feels like a
little little mini christmas every month
i agree thank you bespoke and happy
holidays
okay the whole section is man okay
babe i went ahead and ordered a peloton
comes tomorrow i heard no joke i heard
peloton plus i heard nice big screen i
get to work out at home now look i i
belong to a gym do i want to go do i
need to build up the motivation to go
yes do i go often no
i
every friend i have raves about the
peloton they became a sponsor and it
just kicked me into high gear i placed
an order from one i am so excited for
when it comes tomorrow they have stuff
that i think will motivate me i'm going
to be ordering one soon uh you know like
most new yorkers i don't live in the
biggest department
you get two by four space for it to fly
yeah it's unbelievable well that's the
beauty of it so as soon as i move one uh
one piece of furniture out of my
apartment i will be ordering my peloton
because it will fit in that small space
that's great and you're not gonna feel
like you're alone that's the whole key
to peloton you can do curated playlists
curated instructors uh you can there's
there's there's also different groups
you could join you could you could work
out at the same time with friends you
know you can revisit the same the
instructors you love it's high energy
there's all sorts of cool paths and
things you could watch you don't just
have to be on the bike you could turn
the screen to the side you could take
yoga classes you could do weight
training you could train with bands i'm
super excited to get it i feel like it's
going to be the beginning of my
transformation into i really hope to
look like uh you know um
a young tommy davidson
he had washboard abs if you google it
when he came out great i know yeah i'm
excited to get one of these too every
one of my friends that has one says it's
been life-changing for them and i love
home
i like to do things at home
things are better at home
so i'm all excited about peloton and i
have tried them and i've enjoyed it very
much and i look forward to making one a
part of my everyday life with the
peloton bike there's nothing like
working out from home learn more
at
onepeloton.com new members can try
peloton classes free for 30 days
just by going to one peloton dot com
slash a p p
terms to apply that's o n e p e l o t o
n dot com i'm sick of hearing about
joe's i put a pizza in an oven if you're
gonna sit here and tell me making pasta
is not romantic
on the table stringing it out with the
flower cutting it i mean this is
moonstruck you're talking to me about
dominoes i'm talking about nick cage and
cher in love do you understand what
we're talking about here absolutely not
absolutely not and i'll go back to my
point before i like pasta but inevitably
at every pasta dish i've eaten i'm like
i can't eat anything oh yeah cause pizza
you just light on your feet afterwards
no no what i'm saying is though with
pizza my brain
always wants it i have to overcome my
brain and i have to stop myself from
eating pizza pasta i could do pasta i'm
on autopilot i'm like that was delicious
but i've had too much pasta the pizza
i'm always like
get that i mean i am going to i want
another slice
and i have to literally force myself to
stop eating pizza even when i'm full i
want to see what some of the fans have
to say let's let's
let's go to the phones pip where are we
at i like this one
they're both incredible but you
shouldn't eat either on a first date not
a bad not a bad call by a bed i think
has yeah you get the itis for sure all
right go into let's go to the phones
pamphlet let's see what the [ __ ] argue
the difference in texture between the
two i feel like that's the hardest also
the work the texture the work i want to
do that i'm not done
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait i want to what
do you mean what do you mean the pizza's
crispy it's a crispy vehicle where the
this pasta is sloppy but that's the
thing pizza a lot of the time is not
crispy it's chewy and mushy and it
stinks well every time you're a wet
droopy noodle every time
you're a wet droopy noodle you know what
pasta don't want to hear that but that's
what pasta is texture
you got you got nothing over texture you
cut down through a lasagna with those
layers and the the the
the regatta cheese meaning the
mozzarella cheese with the sauce and the
noodles you got nothing on texture are
you insane pizza is based around texture
i got a very crispy beautiful crust
topped with a hot gooey delicious cheese
and the sauce in between to bring it all
together you even pick up a pizza slice
that's a triangle that's this big and it
doesn't flop that's texture all the way
babe i'm biting into that that
crispiness is what i like to not even
remember the last time i picked up a
slice of pizza and it didn't fly john
travolta saturday night fever babe new
york all the way two slices in one with
the folks
it's even fun to eat pizza i don't want
to do more movie where the guys are
terrible people okay leah yeah i mean
the iconic queen of eleven let's go eat
the terrible people food everybody yeah
let's go into terrible people you know
what i much like that movie when i eat
pasta it's terrible i want to jump off
the bridge as well listen to me
pasta makes you work to eat it i gotta
put on a bib
i'm not wearing oh i'm not wearing a
white shirt or a nice shirt when i'm
eating pasta i gotta put on a bib and
then also what do i gotta do i need a
spoon and a fork and i gotta get it into
the plate and then i gotta get it it
makes you work you don't know how to eat
it makes you work you don't know how to
eat i don't need any of these things
when i pizza is like just your hands all
right so pick
it's more convenient which is probably
why this country is an obesity issue
okay because people can get pizza the
300 miles of pizza people are eating
every day they can eat it while they
walk instead of having to sit down like
a human being i need to cut it with a
knife and fork i need a bowl of pasta
right that's what no one's getting away
no one's getting away from the bowl
maybe stop and breathe while you eat
nope i'm gonna keep on moving okay go
for it buddy
i want to have to twirl every pasta in a
spoon and then get it somebody listen i
like pizza you just pick it up you throw
it in your mouth it's it's communal
you're not sharing your pasta with
anyone else pizza [ __ ] i've had memories
that
are tied to pizza you got your memories
that are tied to pasta are you nuts my
whole family sunday sunday pasta dinners
oh sunday sunday gravy it's generic
that's not generic i'm talking about
specific like oh that party i had uh
generic some of my best memories are
around the table with my family eating
pasta and gravy homemade from scratch i
don't remember any time i pizza with my
okay okay you said earlier that pizza
and pasta usually especially here
available on the same menu in pizzerias
right when you get pizza when you when
you call a pizzeria let's just call it
pizzeria when you call pizzeria to get
delivery to your house the last 10 times
how many times were those deliveries for
pasta and how many times were your last
10 deliveries for pizza we're always for
pizza why would i call a pizzeria for
pasta because they bring you a delicious
plate of pasta hot that you could eat in
your house and you get this thing that
you're telling if i want pasta i i've
got a million choices of of restaurants
in new york city to choose from no no no
no you're not you're not ordering pasta
from a restaurant in new york city or
whatever i want pasta on it with a
hundred other things you know damn well
like oh
order from an italian restaurant i don't
get it from a pizza okay brenda and
eddie oh okay okay
pete's ray says pizza it's not even
close to a competition pizza is the
ultimate food that everyone can enjoy
all the best ideas in the world were
made by people sitting around eating a
pizza what is this nonsense get out of
here ray all right pimp let's go to the
phones we got to wrap this up
all right uh
look before we do i just want to say
savile cattlecomedy.com for my tour
dates uh austin 9 24 denver 9 25
baltimore october 1st durham october
29th everything's on sale right now uh
and another 60 cities will be announced
but get those uh get those tickets come
see me joe derosa comedy
on instagram and twitter joey rose's
opening on the lower east side of new
york yeah very soon very very soon uh
big announcements coming for that and i
started booking road dates for 2022. so
gonna go out on the road again uh i
don't want to announce the dates just
yet because tickets aren't available but
let's sell out these shows and let's
have a good time out there quick tag i
also am fully on the road with the guys
that tour is announced and on sale
there's 50 cities tenderloins.com for
tickets
all right yeah ready okay here we go
powerhouse bad alert oh and check out my
other podcast we'll see you in hell
patreon.com because this one's going
down in flames because he can't even
patreon.com can i can i finish my plug
yeah sorry i didn't step on your
tenderloins
three-minute plug talk about the uh talk
about the talk away
i'm breaking your talk about the podcast
where you don't take l's consistently
[Music]
comments before we look at the i'm
waiting for you to get served i'm
waiting for you to get
all right slow down not pasta either no
matter who loses italy wins also shout
out to carbs
shout out cops i guess so so that bit is
just part of our show now too shout out
to it
i think it's a no pressure thing okay no
pressure i'm sure you said it so can i
start saying it too my goodness yeah
okay i didn't want to bite your [ __ ] i
don't know
what do you mean more in the same
podcast all right but i'm saying it was
a hey bae bit uh i think it was just uh
it
it's not it's pimps
pepe slow down trying to find good ones
it's only a happy birthday because i say
it the uh nobody okay pimpy go ahead i
trust you i'm sorry did i snap i didn't
mean to no no you could no no no
pizza is life i could need it for br i
could eat it for lunch break breakfast
that's true that's true that's right
people pizza you could have for every
meal and be happy i love cold pizza i
used to bring the pizza home and have it
cold pizza we didn't even talk about
cold pizza yes we did i talked about it
with pizza hut
i love cold pizza all right
uh i love pasta but i take pizza all the
time wife swears i'm part ninja turtle
ninja turtles
uh they're not eating pasta i'm gonna
get clobbered turtles
the turtles ain't eating pasta out in
them sewers
yeah congrats wow i guess we thought
pasta would be a good uh i'm waiting to
see what this is because i thought pizza
is gonna work i thought it would be
close but is this a landslide then we
then we then we missed the capacity of
this poll it's oh that's not a good sign
what should go against pizza i don't
let's just see our winner is who was the
kid that wrote the
let's see we already read his name
french fries no i didn't read his handle
though
no oh you know what do me a favor guys
in this one sound off in the comments
what do you think could go up against
pizza let us know what you think could
take pizza it could be my revisit maybe
we will revisit uh let's do a tie for
this week
michael scarn uh follow michael scarn at
l-a-n-u-n-z-17
for his comment about me going to the
nursing home so let's let's give him a
win and then let's also give a tie win
our first ever tie who was the other
comment that we really laughed hard at
yeah yeah the the and then also follow
robert at ice
t h i-c-e-d-o-u-t-t-h-u g
uh iced out thug uh follow them post
i couldn't understand what that said at
first
all right make sure you go follow eyes
out thug
oh my god oh my lord i i actually feel
bad i'm not even going to gloat
i thought that this was going to be i
thought it would be
close i thought you were going to be a
contender i really did i swear to christ
i was a contender i fought a great fight
i can't help with these philistines
voted on the poll
13 13 000 votes
thus far you got pizza humble pie pimp
throw up the uh the meter here
74.1 pizza
to 25.9 pasta
but we misjudged
12 000 we misjudged how people feel
about pasta huh
or
did we just misjudge
how
fervent people are about pizza misjudged
here that's what you misjudged there you
go there you go that's our show how
about that how about that
well i don't know if i still love you
yes you do
i tell you you're gonna say i don't know
if i love you either
how dare you don't do that to me be a
sport
be a sport i just said i'm not even
going to gloat i felt bad for you all
right go ahead
go ahead what say the line all right but
don't be putting pillow points in my
face
i still love you so love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds